everyone it's Ross in today's video
we're going to be pruning some Stone
fruits uh we have just about everything
pruned now like we've done the apples
the pears the Persimmons the Jujubes the
figs all of it uh except for the stone
fruits and the European grapes and that
stuff you need to wait longer uh before
you can prune them sometime in early
spring um late winter and it's really
all about disease with the stone fruits
right we want to prevent that from
happening we want to make sure that in
the forecast it's not going to rain U
before we prune it's really important um
some other things I think are really
important that we're going to talk about
is knowing how your tree fruits okay
does it fruit on New Year's
growth last year's growth or 2-year-old
wood as an example so it could be
one-year-old wood 2-year-old wood you
know it could be any number of things
depending on what it is you guys are
doing I think that's really important
and kind of developing a strategy around
that um you can do this yourself right
um You don't need to follow guidelines
that I'm going to set for you guys or
guidelines that people have recommended
you can just do this your you know
figure out your own little path and do
this however you want to do it um every
tree is different every yard's different
so even though I'm going to give you
guys some recommendations I'm trying to
give you guys General recommendations
here
um these are my cherry trees behind me
they're semid dwarf we're going to move
over there to the asaya peaches in just
a moment but I want to talk about these
first um some things in particular we
have a nice little deer just the nicest
deer that comes through here and makes
its way this way towards the cherry
trees and inevitably every summer or I
should say every
spring he gets a little taste of them
and as a result I've removed most of the
lower growth so that was priority number
one um I also wanted to make sure
that these trees are not getting too big
I want to form a nice little canopy with
these um I want to keep them cuz they're
so close together here I want to keep a
lot of that growth out of the middle to
a minimum and have most of these trees
grow out in the other direction away
from each other um I kind of want them
to be bush-like have a a larger can
a dense
canopy um if I can and that's really the
goal of what I've been decided to do
this year and as you can see we've made
some nice little
Cuts nothing too
drastic but we did reduce the height
quite a bit because I don't want these
trees to get Too
Tall uh the sun about midday is
somewhere around here and if this trees
are too big it's going to shade out
what's on the patio
which would be the Potted figs and those
take priority over the cherries um one
thing about the cherries is
that store-bought quality actually is
pretty similar to Homegrown quality and
if I were to do this all over again I
wouldn't grow sweet cherries probably
would grow some other cherries like bush
cherries or sour cherries that are a bit
more problem free than the the sweet
cherries right the sweet cherries can
really get attacked by rot and
diseases they're not really the longest
live trees either especially in my
climate so you know it's all up to you
guys and where you guys live and your
situation but there are other things
that I would rather
grow um one thing I want to mention here
about the cherries is that they flower
in
clusters I can get the camera to focus
for you this is essentially a nice
little cluster of flowers here there's
about five to seven little buds each of
those will turn into a cherry and they
fruit on or they form I should say on
2-year-old
wood I guess they can probably form I'm
not entirely sure but they can form on
older wood as well but they'll pretty
much stay here for the remainder of
their lives I can come in here and thin
this out these little buds but for the
most part we want to be focusing on
getting a lot of this 2-year-old
wood and
limiting as much one-year-old wood as we
can so it's kind of a bit of a a problem
there um too much one-year-old wood
means we're going to have a huge
tree and too
much well there's no such thing as too
much 2-year-old
wood but we definitely want to make sure
that we're getting a nice little canopy
set up a permanent structure I think is
really what I want to come back to and
really keep these things under control
that way so that's kind of really the
basics of what I have decided to do is
prune out the lower growth for the
deer um kind of control the growth so
it's not growing into each other in its
own little respective
area and also keeping the number of
one-year-old wood kind of to a minimum
right I mean this is about you know a
foot of growth here maybe and that's it
I don't really want any one-year-old
growth more than
that um I mean of course it's going to
grow more than a foot every year but
we're going to keep it trimmed back to
about that and that way we'll form a
nice little almost as if we were poing
this in a way we'll form nice little new
branches here at a lower height than we
would if we kind of just let it do its
thing and let me show you guys the
peaches okay
the peaches are spy a you're not really
supposed to do this but we' we've done
it and these are my tips for this
because I think you need to really get a
little bit creative with these if you're
going to do this
um you can see here this is what we pred
out I left this here for you guys to
see this is only the 3-year-old
wood um obviously there's one-year-old
wood up here right two 2-y old wood as
well but down here this is where the
thick stuff is this is the 3-year-old
wood and this has just got to come
out and the reason for that is that I
can't really control the height of
this and recycle New Growth without
doing that so we made a we only made
three
cuts um that's really it I didn't go
crazy with these you can see we made one
there and then two on this red Haven
Peach right
there um peaches are a bit different I
want to I want to mention here they
fruit on one one-year-old wood the new
growth from last year and they form
these little
buds you can see that there really
perfectly um they'll form about two to
three different Buds and that's that
will be the flowers
whereas this Bud here is really just a
new
Branch um so you have to look at these
branches in a way and say okay how much
fruit do I have and how much do I want
last year I really thinned this out we
got to about a 100 peaches per tree I
think that's
reasonable for someone like me I don't
need to eat more than 100 peaches it's
nice to be able to share but um you know
this stuff down here is really going to
give me a nice little fruit set because
this really has a nice little density of
one-year-old
wood um and that's on the bottom tier
that we're looking at on the second
tier we've actually uh got a similar
situation but it's a bit more vigorous
right as you go up higher on the tree
you get more Vigor so I'm kind of
keeping a lot of the lower stuff because
that stuff's not going to grow all that
much it's not really going to get in the
way of anything too
drastic the second tier we may want to
thin this out a bit more
and really space this out right so this
is like let me give you an example this
is a nice little system of branches
here um this this whole thing that we're
looking at it's got 2-year-old wood it's
got some nice one-year-old branches that
will fruit for
me um we want to space this out between
another little section of 2-year-old
wood this is another good
example so by doing that we're keeping
them apart from each other they're not
shading each other other out we're not
encouraging disease we're increasing air
flow um it's just better off overall for
the
tree um and then we also need to do
something important where we select new
branches that will then become
2-year-old branches this system next
year so if we have a 2-year-old little
complex system of branches here this
will turn 3 years old next year and I
I'm going to take this out I may
keep on the lower tier I may let them
stay here for about four
years on the second tier it's going to
be 3 years and the same thing on the top
tier 3 years as well so any
three-year-old wood has to come out but
we also have to make room for new year
old New Year growth for that to become
something in the future right we have to
be thinking about the future we can't be
so short blindsided here that we just
completely forget about the fruit we're
going to have a couple years from now
you know that's really the goal of these
trees in my mind is that's what I'm
thinking about probably the
most we've got ourselves a nice form
okay that should be your number one
priority from the beginning but once you
get that form down now you're trying to
just manage the number of fruits that
you want so by doing this right by
selecting the the new wood so like if
this is a a nice little permanent Branch
here and this is a nice little permanent
Branch here one of these two would make
a really nice new system to turn into
this or to this the following year and
then if we wanted we could take out one
of these and then that way we would have
a constant
recycling of new wood and new system of
branches it gets a bit more complex as
we get a bit higher and things really
need to be pruned a bit more as we get
higher but it's a similar scenario let
me give you guys a good example
here this is 2-year-old wood and you can
follow this up and you'll see a whole
different system of branches up there
just like we saw
below right next to that is one-year-old
wood that has grown quite vigorously or
maybe it's even 2-year-old wood but you
can definitely see this one back here
this is basically just one little
shot of one-year-old wood this guy back
in there so what we can do is that when
this comes out next year cuz this will
turn 3 years old this time next year we
take this out this then looks just like
that and this will kind of replace that
right so that's all we're doing is we're
Recycling and you get over here into
this section these will
become new branches to eventually
become this 2-year-old section of
complex branches so that's all we're
doing that's really it in a nutshell and
uh I wish I could have said that in
shorter words and less time but uh there
you got
it all
right so again nothing really needs to
be too crazy but uh I did Summer prune
these trees a
bit um so with the connection of Summer
pruning and winter pruning we really
didn't do a whole lot to these trees
what I will do is I'll come in here with
hand
pruners and maybe take out a branch like
this where it's kind of in the way a lot
of crisscrossing branches look for
damaged diseased or dead wood I don't
have any of that on these trees
um you know they're pretty young
but I think you guys kind of get the
idea here so hopefully you enjoyed this
one hopefully you learned something and
if you did please let me know down below
what you
learned and uh I'll certainly be willing
to um help you guys if you have any
questions below all right please
subscribe like the video um check out
the website it's Ross rat. wixsite.com
we had to change the website a bit uh
the link to that will be in the
description all right guys take care and
I'll catch you all soon